hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe I'm your host Sean
Carroll and last time we talked about
scale we had the pleasurable experience
of going back to the real tangible world
just a little bit being a little bit
more down-to-earth after several
lectures on quantum field theory we're
gonna get abstract again over this
lecture and the next one but it's in a
slightly different direction we're gonna
be thinking classically again what we're
gonna be doing is laying some of the
mathematical groundwork for the lectures
to come I keep saying lectures the
videos the ideas to come we have big
ideas they're gonna require a tiny bit
more mathematical sophistication but
it's more conceptual less algebraic and
equation based so I think we'll be okay
but I'm gonna be giving away some of the
ideas that we physicists use all the
time and we don't usually talk about in
popular level treatments of the subject
so today we're going to be talking about
geometry and topology you will notice
these are two different ideas and
they're not really physics ideas they're
completely mathematical ideas so of
course they each are huge subjects which
deserve videos of their own they're not
gonna get I'm going to try to squeeze
both of them into a single video and I'm
going to be concentrating specifically
on very specific aspects of geometry and
topology ones that will be relevant to
what we're gonna be talking about coming
up so it's not gonna be covering the
whole field
so think about geometry and what do I
mean what I mean is non Euclidean
geometry so to make sense of that let me
first talk about Euclidean geometry this
is the geometry that you learned in high
school or wherever you learned it even
if you didn't take any formal courses in
it you've heard about Euclidean geometry
it's the geometry of tabletops it is
sometimes literally called tabletop
geometry it's the geometry of flat
planes and flat three-dimensional
surfaces so Euclidean geometry is things
like if you take a triangle and you add
up the angles inside they add up to 180
degrees
sometimes 180 degrees is called pi
radians just it's a little math back
there but we can use degrees we're not
gonna be try to be too snooty here
that's one fact about Euclidean geometry
here's another fact the parallel
postulate
which is an interesting has an
interesting status let's say in
Euclidean geometry the parallel
postulate says the same thing imagine
you have two lines going off at right
angles to a common line so I'm thinking
these two lines going horizontally
across the page the parallel postulate
essentially says whose different
formulations of it but essentially says
that you continue these lines forever
and they remain exactly parallel they
remain exactly the same distance apart
from each other if they start going in
the same direction and at right angles
to each other okay this is I think the
fifth of Euclid's postulates and it's
one that sort of seems more specific
than the other ones the other ones of
Euclid's postulate is Euclid was a real
person in ancient Greece
who came up with these this
formalization of geometry he had help
but we call it we give him credit these
days and the other postulates are more
or less self-evident like you know that
it's sort of what do you mean by a point
and a line and things like that whereas
this one you know I don't know seems a
little optional and there's been for a
long time this idea that maybe we should
be able to derive the parallel postulate
from other postulates and in fact when I
took geometry for the first time in
junior high school our teacher gave us
an extra credit assignment of junior
high school no high school I guess he
said if you can prove the parallel
postulate from Euclid's other postulates
or the other postulates that we had in
the class then he would give us extra
credit I was ignorant enough to actually
try to do it but I was not stupid enough
to succeed in doing it because you can't
succeed in doing it that's the point the
point about the parallel postulate it is
is it is independent of the other axioms
that's why it's a good axiom if it were
provable from the other axioms you could
remove it from the list of axioms and
one of the reflections of the fact that
it is removable is that you can
contradict it you can have other
postulates that say other things and
that's the birth of non Euclidean
geometry so Euclidian geometry of course
works for triangles works for straight
lines but it works for a whole bunch of
things I mean it's a whole huge subject
of Euclidean geometry about conic
sections and inscribing circles within
squares and calculating areas of things
not going to be talked about any of that
stuff I want
I've right into what happens if we
violate the parallel postulate if we
replace it with something else so there
are basically two choices if you want to
violate the parallel postulate or if you
want to replace it with something else
you might say that well maybe parallel
lines generally focus on each other if
you start off with two parallel lines
that is to say lines that are both
moving at right angles to some common
line segment maybe over space as you
extend them out they come closer and
closer and eventually cross that is
something that could happen it does not
happen Euclidian geometry but you could
imagine it happening you could also
imagine diverging you could imagine
starting with two parallel lines moving
at right angles to a common segment and
as they move off they get further and
further away both completely standard up
completely plausible in other words and
what you could do is you could actually
invent a rule for how quickly they focus
in on each other or how quickly they
diverge and interestingly this was first
done I think in the 1800s by logo chef
ski no chance I'm gonna spell it chef
ski correctly because I don't even think
it's standardized and bullying these are
two loops I should be able to spell his
name correctly they invented what is now
called hyperbolic geometry they worked
independently from each other two
mathematicians in not even get their
countries right I just don't know the
history of this stuff nearly as well as
I know the history of physics but
lobanovsky and bola I both said well
okay what if we in in fact they said
this again I'd never read their papers
but in fact what they said is what if we
examined this possibility that the lines
diverged rather than remaining parallel
and they developed a set of rules for
what is now called hyperbolic geometry
in parallel you can just like you can
prove that the angles in the Euclidean
geometry have interior the angles in a
triangle and Euclidian geometry add up
to 180 degrees in hyperbolic geometry a
triangle sort of looks more like this
because lines diverge
and you can say you can prove that the
angles inside are always less than 180
degrees
how much less depends exactly on the
triangle and exactly how on the geometry
but it's consistently less than that and
this was interesting it's not completely
clear that Lobachevsky and Bolyai were
the first to invent this Gauss Carl
Friedrich Gauss who's one of the
greatest mathematicians of all time he
claimed to have done it first a Gauss
apparently he was one of the greatest
mathematicians he could also be a bit of
a dick apparently he was very fond of
talking to other mathematicians and
being told by the others oh I have some
great new result and Gauss would say oh
yeah I had that several years ago I just
decided it wasn't worth publishing so he
did that exactly to non Euclidean
geometry and usually he I think he was
right most of the time like he he didn't
publish that much but he had a huge
number of results and so gals thought
about this lavash chess game boy I
thought about this and there is a story
that you are sometimes told in the
popular physics literature that goes
something like Euclid invented Euclidean
geometry and then Lobachevsky and Bolyai
invented non Euclidean geometry and that
led right into general relativity the
curvature of space-time so that's true
but it leaves out an enormous amount and
in fact the specific work done by
Lobachevsky and Bolyai and inventing
hyperbolic geometry is not even
specifically relevant very very helpful
let's put it that way to general
relativity at all it's far far too
specific it's also like a little bit
weird in in retrospect it's a little bit
weird because think about a surface on
which you could actually use hyperbolic
geometry like when I'm trying to explain
non Euclidean geometry the most obvious
thing in the world is to look at the
surface of a sphere okay here's a sphere
and you can take a little line segment
being you know for example on the
equator of the sphere and you can shoot
two parallel lines up and guess what's
going to happen they're going to come
together at the north pole or the South
Pole so that's an example of this
focusing kind of geometry not this
diverging kind of geometry so this is
the spherical geometry is very
visualizable whereas if you actually
want to get hyperbolic geometry
people say it's sort of saddle-shaped
and things like that so you can draw a
saddle and you can sort of put a point
there and have two lines that are
initially parallel and they will diverge
from each other dun da da da so a saddle
shape or a Pringle if you're a fan of
the American potato chips saddle or
Pringles shaped geometries are
hyperbolic but there's something nicer
about the sphere than the saddle which
is I can embed the entire 2-dimensional
sphere perfectly accurately inside our
good old 3-dimensional space whereas
this saddle is indeed curved in the
sense of loba chef ski and boy I but
it's not constant curvature they were
actually examining the very very
specific case where the curvature was
exactly the same in all senses and in
all places in your geometry that's true
for the sphere the sphere is completely
symmetric its amount of curvature is the
same everywhere it's it there is exists
a hypothetical two-dimensional geometry
a negatively curved hyperbolic geometry
for which that's true
in the diverging sense but the saddle
does not quite fit that category that
that criterion of being constant
curvature everywhere in the form in
which it's embedded in our 3-dimensional
space so that's a long-winded way of
saying it's actually hard to visualize
absolutely symmetric constant curvature
hyperbolic geometries compared to
spiracle geometries but nevertheless
historically that's what they did they
amended the negatively curved this is
just just to make this clear this is
called negatively curved geometry sphere
it would be positively curved and
Euclidean would be flat zero curvature
okay Euclidean geometry and all these
are possible so it's perfectly allowed
to invent hyperbolic geometry first as
an alternative Euclidian gentleman tree
but it's just weird to meet they didn't
invent a spherical geometry first
however like I'm like I'm hinting at
none of these is what we want in some
sense I mean these are all us
starting point but a very very tiny
starting point we need to work a lot
harder to get what you actually need for
physics out of this
so it was Gauss who first sort of
figured out how to do something more
general what I mean my board general is
let's imagine that instead of
generalizing a flat Euclidean plane two
dimensions instead of generalizing it to
a two-dimensional sphere or a
two-dimensional saddle we just let it be
any old thing okay we just let it be
some wildly diverged thing there's sort
of all lumps here and whatever it has
curvature of arbitrary amounts in
arbitrary directions everywhere
throughout it
okay that's really what you want in
general relativity because we're gonna
get to general relativity eventually and
that says that space-time is curved and
if you ask yourself well it's a
positively curved or negatively curved
well in some places it's positively
curved in other places it's negatively
curved and in fact you need a lot more
information than just positive or
negative to tell me how curved it is
that's what we're gonna develop right
here and Gauss was the one who made the
first steps toward this he was examining
surfaces two-dimensional surfaces and he
figured out different ways to
characterize the curvature at a surface
so for example here's one way that you
could do it take on a sphere take the
North Pole and consider circles lines of
latitude okay around the sphere well
they would have around the North Pole so
they would have a circumference just
like in this flat geometry circles would
have a circumference okay there's a
radius and a circumference and in flat
geometries the circumference is simply 2
pi times the radius 2 pi r that is how
far you have to go around the circle if
you look at this spherical geometry over
here you notice that the circles are
sort of moving toward each other a
little bit compared to what they would
be in the flat geometry so if you try to
calculate the circumference of a circle
in this spherical geometry as a function
of the radius you find that consistently
the circumference is oops that's exactly
what you want to write this conference
is less than 2 PI R every single time
for a circle whereas on this saddle over
here if I were to draw some circles and
I would compare it's hard to see on the
on
thing I drew because it's hard to draw a
negatively curved surface but here the
circumference is consistently greater
than 2 pi R where R is the radius of the
circle so that's one example of what I
mean by characterizing quantitatively
the curvature of the surface once you
say that once you say well okay the
circumference of a circle of fixed
radius is not 2pi or it's something else
maybe what I can do is I can say well
how different is it how less is it of
course it's infinitesimally less but
then I can use calculus to sort of
differentiate take the derivative of how
the circumference is changing as a
function of the radius and I could
characterize that separately at every
point it's not once and for all a
feature of the geometry but at every
point in space I can draw a little
circle or if in three-dimensional space
a little sphere and I can compare how
the area of the sphere or the
circumference of the circle would depend
on the radius compare that to what it
would in flat space to my curved
geometry and I can do that separately at
every point so I get a number at every
point which is how much I'm deviating
from completely flat Euclidean geometry
and that number could be positive or
negative so that's an example of how you
could characterize curvature locally and
it's clear just from you sort of
examples you could imagine in your head
that a curved surface could be very
curved some places not so curved other
places so that's really what you want
and gals figure out how to do this for
this case of two-dimensional surfaces
but then he noticed something cuz he was
one of the greatest mathematicians of
all time he noticed something he noticed
that there are ways of characterizing
the curvature that don't make use of the
fact that this 2-dimensional curvy thing
is embedded in flat 3-dimensional space
so think about there's there's sort of
extrinsic ah sorry my brain was thinking
something else so I wrote badly X
trinsic versus intrinsic curvature
extrinsic is just the curvature you get
from looking at it from the outside
whereas the intrinsic curvature is what
you get from looking at the
inside so if you have let's say this
circle and this is literally supposed to
be a circle on a plane okay so it's a
two-dimensional circle embedded in sorry
a one-dimensional circle embed in this
two-dimensional plane versus let's say
this blobby thing okay so you would say
look well this one is curved but kind of
smooth not that curved this one is also
curved but it's curved in a different
way everywhere
so what gauss says is you're thinking
extrinsically you're thinking about how
the thing looks from the point of view
of the outside but what I want to do
Gauss is I want to think about what if I
were a little person living in that
surface living on the surface of the
circle it's hard to imagine that but I
can imagine being a little person living
on the surface of this two-dimensional
plane or I could imagine that
three-dimensional space itself has
curvature and I could be a person living
in that right so in that case what Gauss
shows is that this circle here and this
circle like thing that is kind of wobbly
have exactly the same curvature in fact
technically they have zero curvature as
we'll see in a second but the point is
that you're moving the circle in the
place where it's living but you're not
changing its intrinsic geometry so what
gals figured out is what you really want
to be able to do is two things you want
to characterize the geometry
intrinsically to where you are and
number two you want to be able to
characterize all the different ways in
which the surface or the volume or
whatever you're in is curved this fact
that circles or spheres change their
area or circumference differently as a
function of the radius is one way but
there could be lots of different ways
lots of different aspects of curvature
and Gauss did not quite finish this
project he didn't quite tackle it all
the way but he had a very talented
student named bernhard riemann riemann
was a brilliant mathematician who went
on to do many great things riemann also
died when he was 39 years old so when
you look at all of the things that
riemann accomplished keep in mind that
he didn't reach the age of 40 before he
did those things so riemann apparently
like he need to write some thesis some
dissertation to get some job in germany
and he went to gauss and said okay here
the different topics
I'm thinking about what's your advice
which one should I do and this is the
story I'm told anyway I'm again don't
know the history very well but Cal said
oh yes this one the foundations of
geometry do that one and apparently
Riemann thought that was the most boring
one that could be done but he did it and
he invented what we now call Romani and
geometry
pretty cool and so what I want to do is
give you some of the fundamental basic
concepts of Romani and geometry
riah Romani and geometry is the answer
to the question if I have not just a
two-dimensional surface but any space of
any number of dimensions so three
dimensional space four dimensional
space-time whatever you want and I
curved it not just uniformly everywhere
but I curved it arbitrarily at any point
okay in different ways at different
locations in space and as we know now
know in time how do I completely
characterize the amount of curvature how
do I know how curved it is how do I
describe that mathematically so he
figured out how to do this and basically
I think that the thing to think about
are straight lines this is my favorite
way of getting into Romani in geometry
what do you mean by a straight line
right well we have one notion of a
straight line is that the straight line
is the shortest distance between two
points okay that's perfectly good so
version 1 is shortest distance and you
can do that you can generalize that
Euclidean notion of I have two points I
take the shortest distance path so in
Euclidean space I take two points da and
I noticed that this shortest distance
path is straight other ones that are not
straight will always have longer
distance if I measure the distance along
them and I can do that equally well in a
curved space so what we call great
circles on a sphere are lines of that
are as straight as they can possibly be
if I take a point that is you know here
at the North Pole and then take another
point that is at the equator and I
connect them there is this is part of a
great circle if I go all the way around
a great circle is just something that is
like the equator but it's not
necessarily at the middle it
anywhere oriented around the sphere and
this is the spherical generalization of
the idea of a straight line you can show
that these great circles are the
shortest distance between those two
points and then you can show other
things like if I do another point there
then the shortest distance here is along
the equator if I connect these there's
another shortest distance curve another
line of latitude sorry longitude in this
case and then I can add up the angles
inside the triangle and they're always
greater than 180 degrees because it's a
spherical geometry you can do all that
stuff okay so that is one version of
what you mean by a straight line how
would you generalize this to a
completely arbitrary geometry well you
know you remember when we did the
principle of least action we had this
idea that there was some quantity the
action that you could get by integrating
over an entire path for a particle or
for some more complicated physical
system then the real path the real
trajectory that obeys the equations of
motion minimizes that action so you can
do exactly the same thing for the length
of a curve but what you need is a way to
calculate the length okay so what that's
what Riemann figured out how to do he he
invented something called the metric the
metric basically is a way of is the
infinitesimal length it's not quite the
in depth in noticeable length all again
this is one of those times when all the
experts in the audience are cringing a
little bit but you know just lighten up
guys it is a way of calculating if I
give you a arbitrary curve and I'm going
to take a little bit of it okay there's
a tiny little segment because I'm
thinking like calculus right this is all
what we call differential geometry it's
all calculus based reasoning where you
take infinitesimal things figure out
what's going on there and then add them
together along some finite size thing to
get the final answer so there's
something that you know called
Pythagoras theorem right that you can
take these if you had ordinary Euclidean
geometry you would say that a a b c if a
is the length of one of the ways you can
go b is a perpendicular way and C is the
hypotenuse then a
squared plus B squared equals C squared
so basically the metric is a
generalization Pythagoras's theorem C
squared equals a squared plus B squared
it says that C squared does not
necessarily need to equal a squared plus
B squared but equals some function of a
and B in fact it's some quadratic
function so it could be something times
a squared plus something times B squared
plus something times a times B okay so
two factors of a and B in general so in
fact let's write it that way so the
infinitesimal length of this tiny little
curve segment here equals something
call it alpha times a squared plus beta
times B squared plus gamma times a times
B okay so the numbers alpha beta and
gamma are telling you how to calculate
the length of an infinitesimal curve in
arbitrarily curved geometry that's what
the metric does and then you can just
add them all together along the curve
it's like a little odometer right here
pushing this little domitor and it's
measuring your path length as you go and
these numbers alpha beta gamma that tell
you how to convert little coordinates
which are what a and B are into physical
lengths which is what C is they could
change from place to place in the
manifold as well as we call this space
of all different points a manifold a
space whatever you want to call it some
curved object in geometry will in
general have a metric that is different
at every point in the manifold I gotta
call it a manifold sorry that's what it
is
so the manifold is this space that is
curved whatever it is how many of our
dimensions it could be by the way bi is
curved I mean could potentially have
curvature maybe it's flat who knows but
it is the space that we will be talking
about when we characterize what the
curvature is okay the curvature of a
manifold so space-time is a manifold a
four dimensional manifold space that we
live in is a three dimensional manifold
the tabletop is a two dimensional
manifold the sphere is a two dimensional
fold and so on okay so the metric is
guess what it's a field on the manifold
it's a kind of field that exists at
every point and at every point answers
the question if I have a little
straight-line segment how long is it
that's what the metric is and I can add
that up to get the length of a finite
sized curve and that's a wonderful way
to do it that's a wonderful way to sort
of generalize what you mean by a
straight line a straight line is the
shortest distance path between two
points you can generalize that to
arbitrarily curved surfaces Riemann
tells you how to do that but there's
another way of talking about a straight
line a straight line can be thought of
as keep walking in the same direction so
if I'm literally on a flat plane and I'm
just walking right if I were to wander
around in different directions what I
would mean is that the momentum or the
velocity or the little vector that
points towards the direction of moving
keeps changing around okay like I move
around and my velocity changes that
vector is sort of wobbling back and
forth as I'm moving whereas in a
straight line I just keep walking in the
same direction as the vector is pointing
as the velocity as I have already been
moving if there is something that says
here's the direction I was moving in
infinitesimally long ago I will keep
moving in that direction now that is
what I'm going to do so in flat space
this idea you're in flat space you have
a point here you are initially walking
in that direction and you just keep
walking in that direction until you
reach some other point you're gonna end
up moving in a straight line okay that's
what you're gonna do so that's an
equally good alternative definition of
what you mean by a straight line
just keep walking in the same direction
that also works in these more
complicated examples if I start walking
north from the North Pole and I just
sorry from the equator and I just keep
walking in the same direction I will end
up doing a great circle path until I
reach the North Pole although everything
I just
goes through so riemann was smart enough
and again I'm not even sure there was
Riemann who did this he sort of got the
answer but I'm not sure what his
reasoning was I shouldn't attribute it
to him but what we realize is that
there's some notion of what do you mean
by keep walking in the same direction
okay you have this vector and you're
saying move in the direction of the
vector the vectors is the the thing that
is pointing in the direction I have been
moving in and what I'm saying is keep
moving in that direction so what I need
is a way to sort of carry vectors along
with me as I travel and if I have that
then I don't need to just do it with a
vector that is pointing in that
direction I mean imagine that I'm
walking around in space carrying a
gyroscope okay just good old ordinary
Euclidean space like a gyroscope and you
might know if you sort of suspend a
gyroscope so that you're not forcing it
in some direction you can just carry it
around in the gyroscope if it's spinning
we'll keep pointing in the same
direction so this is a notion called
parallel transport of vectors it's just
a way of saying you have some vectors
keep them parallel to what they were as
you carry them around keep vectors
parallel to what they were and this
notion that you keep walking in the same
direction is in the lingo of general
relativity you parallel transport your
velocity vector so you have a velocity
vector and you're also have you had this
notion of how to move things keeping
them parallel to each other and a
straight line is one in which if you
have a vector pointing the direction
you're moving you keep parallel
transporting that the vector that is
your actual velocity matches what you
get by doing your original velocity and
just keeping it parallel this is yeah
this is this is what math is all about
you know let me let me just sort of
pause to emphasize this I just said what
a straight line was in two different
ways and we all know what a straight
line is like this is perfectly obvious
thing so why are we complicating it like
this is that's like the worst definition
of a straight line you've ever heard
invent a notion of keeping vectors
parallel as you move and then compare a
parallel transported vector to your
velocity vector and make sure
they line up with each other that is a
definition of a straight line but it
seems a horribly complicated one why it
will be important of courses because
situations are more general than just
flat space we want to be more powerful
we're going to need that extra freedom a
little bit okay so once you have that
you can parallel transport any vectors
so let me let me imagine I have a
different vector so that's what sijjin
at this point I had a vector pointing in
a completely different direction okay
then the notion the idea that I have a
way of telling what it means to keep a
vector parallel means that as I walk
along this path I can parallel transport
the vector with me I can construct a new
set of vectors by just moving in that
direction keeping the original vector
parallel to what it was so I keep any
vector any set of vectors parallel to
what they were as I move along in space
okay the velocity vector the vector this
tells me the direction I'm moving in is
the one that I used to define straight
lines but this is another equally good
this is something I can do once I've
invented that capacity and the reason
why I'm telling you this is because it
gives us a way of telling whether or not
a space is curved that is as powerful as
we're going to get as powerful as we're
going to need because here's the point
what if I start let's do let's do the
sphere again I'll just draw it again I
keep drawing the sphere but that's for
good reason so here's a sphere okay and
here is the North Pole
and here are two points once again on
the equator here and here so we know
what the great circles look like these
are the equivalent of straight lines by
the way the technical term for straight
lines and a curved geometry is a
geodesic but try not to use that jargon
but if you ever hear it that's what it
means and so what if I have a vector
that I will parallel transport so I'll
make it a different color once again so
here I have a vector and it's initially
pointing in that direction I'm going to
move when I walk to the north so I
parallel transport the vectors so
basically I just keep it as parallel as
I can there it is let me move this away
a little bit so
you can see it better and then but then
I want to say okay but now let me do the
same thing but let me parallel transport
along this path along the equator so I
start with the vector and I move it this
way what will happen is by parallel
transporting it it's not my velocity
it's just a vector I'm carrying along by
parallel transporting it it will always
remain perpendicular to the direction
that the Equator is in parallel
transport has the nice property is that
if two vectors start perpendicular they
always remain perpendicular as you move
them so I parallel transport it along so
here's the first path and now this
second path I move along the equator and
now let me keep moving this second path
so I now parallel transport it upward so
I take the vector that I have moved
along the equator and now I move it up
to the North Pole and what do I find
I find that when I get to the North Pole
even though in both cases on the orange
curve and the yellow curve I've been
parallel transporting a vector
everywhere I've gone I've ended up with
two different vectors the vector that I
ended up with on the short distance
orange path is different than the vector
I end up with on the longer distance out
of the way yellow path why because the
sphere is curved on a flat plane that
would not have happened on a flat plane
if I parallel transport something on any
curve I want so here's a flat plane I
can take a vector here's a vector and I
take some path no matter how complicated
it is don't aah my parallel transport
the vector well no problems just remains
pointing the same direction the whole
way my parallel transport it along a
different path like that I can ask what
happens there the answer is the same
kind of thing and I will end up with the
same vector so this is yet another
characterization of a way in which
curvature shows up in
geometry we said it showed up because
angles inside triangles were different
it shows up because the relationship of
the radius of the circle to its
circumference is different it also shows
up in the way that vectors change when
you parallel transport them okay if
you're in a flat space they don't change
at all if you're in a curved space they
change a lot this is a reflection of the
fact that if you're in a curved space
there's no way of saying when you have
two vectors at different points in space
or different points on the manifold
different points in space-time whatever
you want to say two separated vectors
there's no unique way of saying are they
the same or are they parallel okay that
is not a well-defined notion because to
compare them you have to move them next
to each other and moving them next to
each other is the best you can do is to
parallel transport it and that was going
to depend on the path you take to
parallel transport it so when someone
says for example when cosmologists say a
distant galaxy has a velocity of so and
so many kilometers per second they're
kind of lying to you at least they're
being casual with the truth what they're
saying is that there's a redshift of the
photons coming from that galaxy which is
equivalent to analogous to having a
certain velocity but there's no
absolutely in general relativity
well-defined velocity between two things
at different points in space because it
there's no way of comparing them and
this is why if you go far enough away in
an expanding universe you will find
objects that have an apparent velocity
greater than the speed of light and you
will say to yourself wait a minute
relativity told me that they can't have
velocities greater than the speed of
light the answer is it's not a velocity
it's just an apparent kind of thing that
is analogous to a velocity and the
analogy breaks down when you're too far
away okay so this is a little bit of
abstract nonsense but it gets us
something important that parallel
transporting a vector is a way of
defining straight lines and a way of
characterizing the deviation from
curvature the problem with the pictures
I've drawn here is of course these lines
these curves I have a parallel
transported around are big right if
they're long they're finite sized and
what I want is something that will
characterize the curvature at every
point in space
so what we want to do we won't do the
calculus thing we want to shrink
everything down to infinitesimally small
but also these curves I've drawn are
kind of you know arbitrary and random
right you want a way to sort of
systematize the curves we're drawing so
here's what we end up doing in Romani
and geometry to characterize the amount
of curvature at one point in space we
say I define a loop around which you are
in a parallel transport a vector but
it's an infinitesimally tiny loop so
rather I mean the loop is just an
arbitrary thing that would require an
infinite amount of information to tell
you the location of every point on the
loop what I want to do instead is say
here is a vector call it v1 and here's
another vector v2 I'm going to define an
infinitesimally tiny parallelogram by
saying move in the direction of V 1 then
move in the direction of V 2 then move
back in the direction of V 1 again so my
curve is go this way go that way go back
that way and then come back to where I
started okay this might make you a
little bit uneasy because how do i
define a parallelogram if space is
curved and everything the answer is as
long as I am infinitesimally small this
all makes sense there's a way to make
this completely rigorous using
derivatives instead of finite size
vectors but it can be done the point is
I define a loop in space time not by
giving you some arbitrarily weird curve
but just by giving you two vectors I say
there's V 1 V 2 and I make a loop by
saying go down V 1 then V 2 then back
along V 1 back along V 2 I come back to
where I started and what I do along the
way is I will take a vector and I will
parallel transport it so here's my
vector let's call it V 3 and I'm gonna
parallel transport it so I'm going to
keep it as parallel as I can first along
V 1 then along V 2 then back along V 1
and then back along V 2 and what I end
up with is that it has changed
v 3 has moved too
a slightly different value that is to
say v3 itself hasn't moved when I
parallel transport around the loop just
like in this sphere up here I get a
different answer so in the sphere I went
along two different paths to get from
one point to a different point but I
could have just gone along one path that
was a closed loop equally well so what
that does and this is this is the payoff
here that defines a fourth vector V for
loops to be consistent that should be a
lowercase index right so what I get by
starting with v1 and v2 and defining a
little loop and being given V 3 in
parallel transporting v3 around that
loop is a fourth vector V 4 which says
by how much did the original vector
change when I went around that loop and
I do all this in a very very
emphatically tiny region of space so I
do it at every single point basically I
only need to know what's happening in
the infinitesimally small location of
that point so what I get at the end of
the day is the following piece of
information I get a map from three
vectors V 1 and V 2 which define the
loop around which I went and V 3 which
defined the vector that I was parallel
transporting into one vector V 4 which
tells me by how much did V 3 change okay
so this thing remember I told you like
way back when that all of math is just
talking about maps between different
spaces okay this is a map this is read
mr. Riemann says you have a map from
three vectors to one vector this is like
a little machine at every point it's a
black box that says if you give me these
three vectors I'm gonna spit out a
fourth vector and we have a name for
this machine this is called the Riemann
curvature tensor and again no one's
gonna tell you this until you take
general relativity or you listen to
these videos so a tensor is a
generalization of the idea of a vector
you know the vector is a set of
components a tensor is a bigger
collection of no
arranged either in columns or rows or
matrices or cubes or something like that
but it's a whole big kind of set of
numbers that can tell you a map from a
set of vectors to another set of vectors
that's all it is it's a way of mapping
vectors to vectors and the Riemann
curvature tensor is this particular map
so the Riemann curvature tensor
specifies at every point at every point
you can do this you give me a point I'm
going to give you two different vectors
I'm going to track parallel transport
around a third vector and see how much
it moves by that's the value of the
Riemann curvature tensor at that point
and it's a lot of information because
you have to give me that value of V for
for every possible value of V 1 V 2 V 3
right now happily everything is vectors
so you only have to get me some basis
vector information I can figure it out
the rest for myself every vector is a
certain linear combination of basis
vectors so there's a finite amount of
information you have to give me at every
point and professor Riemann tells us
this is a tensor that describes the
total amount of curvature at every point
in space okay so this seems like a lot
of work I think it seems like we're
doing a lot of work and we are doing a
lot of work and if I were to attach all
the mathematical you know formalism to
this way of doing things it would be
considerable it would go on but it's
worth it then the Riemann curvature
tensor is exactly what is used in
general relativity to characterize the
curvature of space-time okay but by
doing by going so again usually in pop
physics treatments we don't go to
through quite this much detail and we
don't tell you about parallel transport
and we don't tell you about the rebound
curvature tensor let me reveal why it's
worth trying to do it okay
this information what I'm doing is
deriving what I said oh yeah this let's
go back up here what I did here for the
shortest distance definition of a
straight line is saying you need to give
me some data you need to give me some
information about the manifold whose
curvature you want to know and I can
figure out what the curvature is on the
basis of that data what is the data in
this way of thinking it is the metric it
is the way of calculating a distance
along a little tiny infinitesimal path I
could add up
a longer path to get the distance along
any path and then I can figure out what
a straight line means and from that
information what you can show is you can
also calculate areas and volumes and
what it means to be perpendicular and a
whole bunch of different things the
metric the metric tensor field is the
fundamental thing in general relativity
is the thing that is the equivalent of
the electromagnetic field or whatever is
the starting point for doing general
relativity but then I give you a whole
other way of doing it
saying that I could think about
curvature and straight lines and
deviations therefore they're from based
on this idea of keep walking in the same
direction keep things parallel
transported and if you notice in this
page that I'm showing you right now on
the screen there's no distances though
idea of a distance didn't appear
anywhere I didn't need to tell you what
the distance was or how to calculate it
how is that even possible if the whole
foundation of geometry was this metric
thing which told me the distance how do
I get another way of calculating the
curvature without even mentioning what
the distance is so the answer is that I
needed to give you some data once again
I needed to give you data that revealed
the answer to the question what does it
mean to parallel transport vectors how
do I know how to keep a vector constant
as I move it along a path and what that
means is in other words so parallel
transport from one point to another is a
way of basically this is some curved
manifold I have point a point B I have
some path that I move on and then some
vector that I'm going to parallel
transport along the path parallel
transport away of comparing vectors at
different points in space so if you like
it's a way of connecting what's going on
at one point in space to another so it
requires data or information and an
answer to the question what does it mean
to keep things parallel in the form of a
connection which is a field just like
the metric which tells me what is the
distance along an infant decimal path
the metric exists at every point it's a
field that can take on different value
the connection is the answer to how does
how do i parallel transport vectors and
it is also a field so at every point I
have a way of parallel transporting
vectors in every direction so it's a
complicated mathematical object and I
call that a connection if you just want
to think about what do you mean by a
connection it's a field that tells me
how to parallel transport things it
conveys that information what does it
mean to keep things constant to keep
things parallel along a path where a
parallel transport them okay and the way
that romani and geometry works is the
connection defines the curvature so I
have a way of parallel transporting
things and I define the Riemann
curvature tensor in terms of the result
of that parallel transport so the
curvature of space-time or of any other
space that you have is a function of the
connection now it turns out as I said
that these two notions of straight lines
keep the vector parallel and minimize
the distance along the paths are the
same they're equivalent to each other
you can map them match them right up to
each other so what that means slightly
more formally is the metric defines a
connection and this is the way that
romani and geometry works the metric
which is telling me the distance between
two different points anywhere is
secretly and again I'm not going to all
the details but provides a way for me to
define what it means to keep vectors
parallel as I move them and that's the
piece of information I need to figure
out what the curvature is so this is the
missing step that they that they don't
usually tell you about they might tell
you about the metric and distances and
they'll tell you about curvature but in
between there is the connection and the
reason why I'm emphasizing it is because
we will see contexts in which there's no
such thing as a metric there is only a
connection and only a curvature so the
metric is a special thing in general
relativity and the reason why is because
the vectors you're moving are literally
vectors pointing in some direction in
space-time once we get to field theory
once we get to in fact what are called
gauge theories in
article physics we're going to be
parallel transporting vectors that are
much more abstract senses of the notion
of the word vector so like quark vectors
that don't point in any region any
direction of space but they point in
color space the space of quark colors
red green blue things like that and all
this machinery of geometry connections
parallel transport curvature etc is
still there in gauge theories of
particle physics even though the metric
is not there so I'm sort of killing one
two birds with one stone it's an
incredibly complicated abstract stone
but nevertheless okay that's how it
works it's it's worth doing it I think
good I think that's all we need about
geometry now so I remember just trying
to repeat myself because they are hard
concepts honestly like you know I get it
this is what we're trying to get we're
trying we're trying to say that this
notion of parallel transport lets us
define the curvature at any point in
space we can relate it to this other
notion we had of the metric and it all
fits together a nice geometric bundle in
fact you know when we thought about
Newtonian physics versus the principle
of least action the Newtonian laplacian
way of thinking about the laws of
physics was start with a point and just
chug forward using F equals MA you get
the same answers doing things that way
as you do with the principle of least
action which says take the whole path
and minimize the action along the path
you might think is this analogous to
these two different ways of defining
straight lines the whole path and find
the minimum length or parallel transport
your direction your momentum vector and
the answer is yes they are a hundred
percent completely analogous it's the
differential version versus the integral
version if you want to think about it
that way okay so that's geometry for you
there it is that's all you need to know
everything else is derived from that in
some sense but the derivations might be
hard next we're on to topology topology
is sort of the opposite in some sense of
what we've been doing so what we've been
doing is working really hard to figure
out how at every point to characterize
the to answer the question how curved is
this space that we're living in topology
doesn't care about the curvature of
space at every point at all topology is
the study
properties of spaces in the most broad
sense of the word space manifolds or
whatever you want to call them that are
the same that do not change under smooth
deformations okay invariants if you want
to say it under smooth deformations so
what I mean by that the well what I mean
is let's say I have this circle which is
a little wobbly and this circle which is
also all bleedin different way these are
completely topologically the same I can
just deform one of them into each other
no problem just by moving around the
circle in different ways if I have a
sphere okay and versus a torus right
like a tube that I glue the different
ends together these are not
topologically the same I can not deform
a sphere into a torus I can deform a
torus into a coffee mug I can't draw the
coffee mug very well here but you know
coffee mug has a little handle like this
there's one handle in and okay there's
one hole in it so it turns out that I
can actually deform a coffee cup into a
donut this is the joke topologists or
mathematicians who don't know the
difference between a coffee cup and the
donut but we don't want to be able to
just say those things and do pictures
about them we want to be more
quantitative we really want to classify
what it means to be topologically the
same versus topical topologically
different okay so these smooth
deformations would have been by smooth
deformation the technical term which we
won't be using that often they'll tell
you is homeomorphism and sadly there's
another word homomorphism there sounds
almost the same except for letter e but
means something different okay so a
homeomorphism
in is a topological way of saying what a
smooth information is it's basically a
smooth map and by the way mathematicians
have very very technical
nations of the word smooth I'm not gonna
tell you what that means and probably
there's even different notions of the
word homeomorphism it might just be a
continuous map is enough I'm not even
sure but for our level of rigor a smooth
map with a smooth inverse I think it is
continuous actually it's all we need
but who cares so what does this mean you
know obviously if I have these two
circles I can smoothly map one to the
other there's no problem at all
what why do I need to smooth inverse I
mean clearly it's a bear in the case of
the circles but why do I care well think
about the plane okay
or r2 in Matthew language right the two
copies of the real numbers real numbers
times themselves two-dimensional space I
can smoothly map that to a point there
you go just by saying everything maps to
a point okay and you might say well okay
therefore the plane and the point are
topologically the same but I can't go
backwards
there's no smooth continuous map from a
point to the plane okay because there's
only one point it can't map equally in
some deterministic way to every single
point in the plane so the plane and the
point are not topologically the same
okay there is no homeomorphism between
the point in the plane in fact one thing
that we call a topological invariant one
feature of a space that does not change
under topology is the dimensionality of
the space so r2 the plane is
topologically different from the point
which is a zero dimensional space or the
line which is a one dimensional space or
three dimensional space or anything like
that the dimensionality of the space is
topologically invariant and this is so
there's good news and bad news when it
comes to topology again what we want to
do is when a study all the ways in which
we can smoothly deform things and we
would like ideally to classify all
possible topologically distinct spaces
right all the different ways that we can
have a space that cannot be
topologically smoothly deformed into
another space it turns out that I think
it's impossible at least it's certainly
not something that we're anywhere near
doing what we do instead is a piecemeal
kind of attack
where we say here are ways of
distinguishing between spaces and you
know that if these things which we call
topologically topological invariants
topological invariant is something that
does not change under this kind of
smooth map topological invariants so I
said the dimensionality of space is a
topological invariant and what we try to
do is invent ways to calculate a whole
bunch of topological invariants and then
we know if if two spaces have different
invariants even if it's just one of them
then we know those spaces are
topologically in equivalent not the same
to each other so how do we do that in
practice well in practices again there's
a hodgepodge of different ways so I'm
going to tell you is a way of doing it
called Homa toppy sorry all the words
look more or less the same but they are
different
Homa toppy is mapping spheres into
spaces and asking how many topologically
different ways are there to map a sphere
into a space there are other topological
invariants there's homology there's Co
homology the whole bunch of different
things but home atop e is a way that is
kind of funny because physicists like it
because home atop E is a character of a
space that shows up again and again in
physical situations but mathematicians
do not like it because it's really hard
to calculate homotopic groups in general
homology groups in ecology group spaces
are actually much more easy to calculate
in many cases but they're not let as
physically relevant released not as
directly physically relevant they
certainly are relevant in certain
circumstances but not as immediately as
home and topic groups are so in fact
home atop e groups and I'll explain what
that means maybe who knows what does
this mean so again all of math is about
mapping spaces in between to each other
and looking at the different properties
of the maps so let's say let's consider
the set of maps from a circle okay one
dimensional circle remember it's not the
interior the circle and I draw a circle
it's just the one dimensional actual
circle itself that I'm talking about
that's why it's labeled s
one one-dimensional circle let's I take
maps from the circle into some space
let's say R to the plane okay and
secretly I keep the base point fixed so
what I mean by that is I have here's R
to the plane I take a circle I map it
into it and I fix some point on the
circle and I fix some point in the plane
so that that point on the circle always
maps to the same point in the plane and
then I say okay I'm gonna map it here we
go there is a certain map of the circle
into the plane what I claim is I can
smoothly deform every such map into any
other such map so here's a different map
of the circle into the plane starting
from the same base point okay I can just
smoothly deform one to the other its
kind of obvious in this example in fact
I can smoothly deform all of them to a
single point at the center at the base
point where it doesn't move so there's
nothing interesting going on in this
this is called so let me let me give you
all the lingo here this set of maps from
the circle to a space so topologically
equivalent not gonna lie see defined
what that means but you more or less
know what I mean
topologically equivalent Maps from the
circle into some space X is known as the
fundamental group of X
and just to make it a little bit more
interesting here
let's take Maps from the circle I don't
need I need to this space here from the
circle two or two minus a point so what
I mean is here is r2 again but now I
remove one point I should get a certain
ice color here I remove this point that
gray point
okay that's not in my space anymore I'm
gonna map a circle here's my eeap's
here's my circle with my base point
their base point here I'm going to map
the circle into the plane - a point okay
what that means is when I do my
deformations of the circle I'm not
allowed to move it through the point
because the point is not there the point
is not part of the manifold so I can
think about this map of the circle but I
can also think about this map of the
circle and I cannot deform one into the
other I cannot do that smooth movement
of the circle in this plane that doesn't
go through the point so these are
topologically different okay so the
fundamental group of the plane is just
trivial it's just one element there's
only one way to map a circle into the
plane but the plane - a point I clearly
have different ways this orange curve I
can deform back to the identity and by
the way I should mention this there's a
sense there's a direction so the circle
has a clockwise Nisour anti-clockwise
Ness notion so let me draw that I've
drawn it this way I can that's that's a
different topological class okay loops
in the plane that go once around that
point cannot be deformed back to zero
you're not gonna be surprised when I
tell you there are also loops that go
twice around and then come back might be
hard to actually follow the picture but
this is what is actually happening
okay I cannot deform the loops that go
around twice to either the loops that go
around once or the loops that go around
zero times what this means is they put
braces around here so you know that this
is the space I'm mapping it to the
fundamental group of the plane - a point
is characterized by something we call
the winding number of the map we have
all sorts of ways of mapping the circle
into this space and all that matters
topologically is how many times the
circle wraps around winds around that
point so the winding number could be 0
for the orange curve it could be 1 for
the yellow curve it could be 2 for the
green curve guess what it could be minus
1 here's a map of the circle that goes
the opposite sense okay and I could have
minus 2 and minus 3 and minus 4 so the
different topological ways of mapping
the circle into the plane minus the
point are characterized by a number the
winding number which could be 0 1 2 3 or
it could be minus 1 minus 2 minus 3 etc
in other words it could be any integer
so it's the integers that's the
fundamental group of the point of the
plane - a point the integers and in math
speak for the integers you write this
fancy Z Z is the integers all the
integers remind me to infinity by units
of 1 from 0 1 2 3 - 1 - 2 - 3 whereas
the fundamental group of our two where'd
it go
yeah yes so the fundamental group here
is just the trivial group call it 0
as opposed to the integers okay so this
is a topological invariant the value for
any one particular that the topological
invariant here is not a number it's a
whole space the topological invariant is
Z the integers the integers are the
fundamental group of the plane - a point
so that's a whole geometric structure
that's why it's called a group because
you can add integers together we'll get
later to what the technical definition
is well what I mean by group but the
point is this is a top this feature of
the space is a topological invariant and
the feature is quote-unquote the
integers the integers classify the
winding numbers the first the
fundamental group of the plane so we can
do that with other spaces right what
about the sphere so what we're the to
the 2-dimensional sphere in this case
right so actually then let's do the one
dimensional sphere why we're at it so
what I mean by that is the fundamental
group will be maps from the one
dimensional sphere into the one
dimensional sphere s 1 to s 1 ok so here
is my initial s 1 I'm going to map it
into another s 1 with a base point and
guess what I'm not going to do this in
great detail but it's exactly the same
story as the plane - a point namely I
can go around once like that like the
yellow curve I can go around 0 times I
can just map it like this then loop back
I can go around 2 times then go back I
can go backwards these are all different
ways of mapping one's circle into
another circle so the fundamental group
in this case is again the integers
fundamental group of s 1 is Z so this is
already something interesting here and
this is why typologies hard and this is
why home atop B is not necessarily
beloved by mathematicians we said that
the fundamental group of
or to minus a point is the integers
fundamental group of the circle is the
integers but they're not the same
topological space right because the
plane - a point is still a
two-dimensional space even though I
removed a point from it so there is a
topological invariant of the plane -
point namely its dimensionality and that
equals - there's a topological invariant
for the circle with its dimensionality
which equals one so they're not
topologically equivalent but they're
fundamental group is equivalent so what
this is telling us is that the
fundamental group of two spaces being
different is sufficient but not
necessary for two topological spaces to
actually be different themselves the
circle is not topologically equivalent
to r2 - a point but its first but its
fundamental group is and I think you if
you want to know why I keep stumbling
and saying first it's because so the
fundamental group in general is the set
of topologically equivalent but I'm not
going to keep writing the set of
topologically equivalent Maps from s1
into your space X but there's also
consider maps from an N spear into X
what does that mean so s1 equals a
circle right and how do we define that
well one way defining it is embedding it
in a plane or some Euclidean space and
just saying take all the points distance
one from the from the origin that's what
you mean by a circle it's not the best
definition of a circle but it's a
definition of the circle so s2 is a
sphere which means that we start with
some three-dimensional space and we look
at all of the points equidistant from
the origin and that's a two dimensional
thing s2 this is s1 and we can have
three-dimensional spheres four
dimensional spheres and dimensional
spheres and we can map any of them into
any space and we can deform them around
and these are called the length home
atopic group and the notation is PI n of
X so the reason why I keep saying first
is because in my life I never use the
phrase fundamental group I use the
phrase the first home atop e group the
first home atopic group the set of
circles ways that I can topologically
differently map circles into spaces is
sometimes known as the fundamental group
so it's an easier thing to remember but
you can also map to Speers three spheres
four spheres and then you get the second
home atopic group the third home atop a
group of the fourth on the topic group
you can even map 0 spheres as 0 and this
is why I told you that the definition of
a sphere is the set of points
equidistant from the origin you already
knew the definition of a sphere why they
bothered that with you s0 is a set of
two points because I start with the real
numbers ok
and I take two points equidistant from
them like plus one and minus one that is
together the 0 sphere as 0 and therefore
this kind of fun so PI 0 of some space X
some topological space is maps from s 0
into X with a fixed base point so I only
have two points and I'm mapping them
into some space but one of them I'm not
allowed to move right so the other one
I'm allowed to move and basically what
that's doing is just counting the number
of disconnected pieces that end it that
X falls into so let's imagine that x
equals 2 circles s1 plus s1 circle 1 and
circle - ok so they're just circles but
there's two of them so then I map my s 0
o my 0 sphere into them so that means I
take let's move this over here
that means I take two points
and I map them here's one point one
point but I fixed the base point so this
is point a point B and a always maps to
here B can map to either here or it
could map to there okay and then if it
does either one I can always deform it
back to the base point or the equivalent
and the other one so the number of
different ways I can kapa logically map
two points with a fixed base point into
a space it's just the number of
disconnected pieces that the space falls
into so there's even a PI zero there's
even a zeroth OMA Tom P group okay let
me give you another two examples that
are kind of fun well there may be three
examples that are kind of fun the torus
the torus is actually s1 times s1 so
there's a difference when you say s 1
plus s 1 that means you have two copies
of the circle when you have s1 times s1
you have a circle at every point of the
other circle ok so that means that you
really multiply them together and that's
where you get the cylinder that is sort
of joined it together ok so that's a
torus you all know the torus is it's the
surface of the donut I'm not going to go
through any complicated calculation here
but if I map a circle in do the torus
and I ask how many different ways I can
do it it's not gonna be a surprising
answer so I have an s1 and look I'm only
going to consider the fundamental group
for right now so s1 here it is I map it
into the torus
well there's basically three things that
can happen one thing is nothing so
here's my base point make it white
here's my base point one thing that can
happen is I just don't wrap around
anything at all so that's sort of the
zeroth element another thing that can
happen is I can wrap around the circle
the torus this way ok and another thing
that can happen is I can wrap around the
circle this way and those are different
things that green circle and that orange
circle cannot be continuously deformed
into each other there's basically two
distinct topological ways of wrapping a
and the Taurus and once I wrap around
once I can wrap around any number of
times so that is a very quick hand wavy
demonstration of the fact that PI one of
the tourists is Z plus Z it's two copies
of the integers two different winding
numbers how do you wind around this way
how do you wind around that way so you
might think you might think for these
brief numbers of examples that the
fundamental group PI one of any space is
either zero or it's the integers or some
copy of the integers and basically what
you're doing is you're counting how many
holes there are in the space and for
every hole in some sense you get a copy
of the integers because you can wind
around the hole you might think that
you'd be terribly terribly wrong of
course you'd be terribly wrong what what
do you think your life is gonna be easy
for us so how about the plane minus two
points okay the plane are two that's
almost like the torus in the sense that
plane minus two points that's let's
label these two points a and B now I can
ret I can map a circle into it here's my
circle s1 I'm going to map it in there
calculate the fundamental group of the
plane minus two points and it looks like
you're gonna guess I could go around a
or I can go around B so there's two
different winding numbers and you're
gonna guess that the fundamental group
is again two copies of the integers Z
plus Z maybe you're not gonna guess that
but it would have been very reasonable
for you to guess that so and of course
of course of course I'm going through
this because it's not that easy it's not
like that quite that simple nothing I
draw many different things that's gonna
get a messy picture here but here's
imagine starting here imagine that I go
around a and then I go around B okay so
I first go around a then go around B
that's a single curve so I can just
again it's topology I can deform it into
whatever thing I want so that's like
just going around both of them at the
same time okay and I'm not gonna quite
finish this because I'm not done yet
so imagine you go around and then
around being and imagine that you
thought that there was a winding number
for a and a winding number for B
separately so then if that were true I
should be able to go backwards around a
and backwards around B and I come back
to where I started so if I go to you
know the let me just do this quickly and
then erase it in the original example of
the plane with one point removed if I
went around that point and then instead
of finishing I went around backwards I
get another curve that is deformable to
zero right that doesn't wind at all and
that's a that's a perfectly good
reflection of the fact that in the
integers Z has the property that plus 1
plus minus 1 equals zero right
not a very profound mathematical fact
but there it is so if that were true if
it were true that the same kind of thing
was happening in this doubly punctured
plane I should be able to go around a
and then around B and then I should be
able to go backward around a and
backward around B and I should be
equivalent to not doing anything at all
but that's not actually what happens
let's see it's unlikely I can draw this
in a convincing way but backward around
a means this and backward around B means
this ok so do this at home do this with
yarn and sticks or something like that
or rocks or whatever this curve cannot
be deformed
back to the identity ok and that means
what that means is that the front
fundamental group of the plane minus two
points is not just two copies of the
integers in fact I'm gonna we're gonna
peek ahead a little bit this is a non
abelian group which means that
operations don't commute with each other
so I'm making too much of this because
this is not the point of this video but
what I mean is what we're doing here is
we're saying go around day usually we
work from right to left when we do these
mathematical operations I don't know
exactly why but that's the reality so go
around eh then go around B then go
backwards around a then go back around B
and if it didn't matter what order the
operations were in I could take these
middle ones and I could just change
their order so let's see if I can do
this I think I can move this over here
this over here move this over here okay
and now in this order it's clear that
back around a and around a just cancel
each other and back around being around
B just cancel each other and this is
equivalent to doing nothing zero but it
in fact it's not equivalent to doing
nothing because I can't rearrange the
order like that that's what it means to
be a non abelian collection of
operations abelian means everything dis
commutes with each other non abelian
means it doesn't so the fundamental
group of some arbitrary topological
manifold need not be abelian okay there
you go
I spent far too much time spinning that
but it's true it's an important fact
okay the last example that I want to
give you and this one actually is
relevant consider the disk okay so a
circle is just the one dimensional space
around what you normally think of as the
interior of the circle the disk is that
one dimensional space and the interior
okay so it's a two dimensional thing
that goes out to the circle and then
does not include the outside so here's
the disk
okay the interior of this I'm not sure
let's see can I possibly color this in
effectively I don't know yeah maybe so
this is the disk but I'm going to
complicate our lives a little bit by
saying the disk with opposite points
identified so this is again like that
asteroids game or whatever when you go
in this side you pop out that side okay
that's what it means opposite points
identified you're not identifying the
whole circle some of you might know that
if you take a disk and you identify all
the points on the circle as a single
point you just wrap things up into a
two-dimensional sphere that is not what
we're doing we're saying this point here
gets identified with that point here but
not with this point over there okay so
that is this is a space disk lops if one
is identified if you want to lingo
this is the projective disk oops I want
to stop doing that because I want to
undo all those vectors I drew on this
yeah so this is called the projective
disk or the projective plane and it has
a really interesting feature when you
calculate its fundamental group so I
have a circle face point right s1 gonna
map it in there so clearly there are non
contractable loops there are ways to map
the circle into this disk which I cannot
undo watch I start here at a single
point and is go over here then I pop
back okay so I wrap once around you
might say well I deform it a little bit
but if I start deforming it here like
that then this also deforms like that
okay so they're not ever gonna meet up
this is a honest-to-goodness non
contractable map of a circle into the
sphere into the into this disk with
opposite points identified so then what
you're thinking is well then there's a
winding number right I could what wind
around twice or three times or four
times right they go backwards for all
those different things turns out
it's not quite true so let me show you
how to do that I'm just gonna make
another disk
here's another disk I'm gonna paint it
in using my skills oops that's an eraser
where's my yeah there we go painting the
disk opposite sides are identified I
don't know how to indicate that but
you'll trust me on it
and what I'm gonna do is to try to
construct what you might think is the
next non-trivial loop by going around
twice so I will start here go around and
then since I'm gonna be around twice
I'll make my life a little bit easier by
changing colors then I'll go around here
okay and then I will come back here make
it white again so if this is a this is
also a and this is B this is also B okay
so you've gone around twice what I want
to do is deform this into well what I
want to say is can I deform this at all
or is it truly wrapped around twice in a
topologically distinct way so the answer
is I'm gonna stop doing this coloring in
thing it just takes me too long okay so
here's an attempt here's what happens
start here two lines like that i deform
one by moving it up a little bit
so the first one still goes there and it
comes out but then it's gonna go up here
so that means it comes over there that
goes to that I'm gonna keep going so you
can see what's happening here my base
point is fixed but I have this so I'm
going to make it go down and that's
gonna go up this is gonna go like this
I'm gonna keep going
and then I can just pull this all the
way through
so in other words I can contract this
down to zero I hope that that's followed
what I did here if I call this a a b b
this is a a the be a a the be a a b b
and they just contract right through
again try this at home it's hard to do i
wish i'd like animations or something
like that but i can wrap around once in
the disc with opposite sides identified
and i cannot contract it but if I wrap
around twice then I can contract that
circle back down to the identity so the
fundamental group of Pi one if you want
of discs with opposite points identified
has one identity element that you can
always map the circle in there and some
deformable way down to zero and it has
one wound element as one non-trivial
element but if you want it twice you go
back to zero okay so what that means is
this equals z2 which is the notation we
use for integers modulo two I should
write it in a legible way sorry the
interest dirt integers modulo two are
just the integers with the rule that one
plus one equals zero so that you go from
zero to one but then instead of going to
two you go back to zero again so it's
just the numbers zero and one with the
rule zero plus zero equals zero zero
plus one equals one one plus one equals
zero
that's the integers modulo two it's a
set with only two elements and that's
what this disk has it has two different
ways of mapping a circle into it
topologically either the completely
trivial way or the way the wraps around
exactly once so you don't have to be
able to classify every topological space
in terms of winding numbers that are
integers okay you can have more subtle
situations like this one we're winding
twice as the equivalent winding zero
times and then you can go on Yelp
full-employment right you can calculate
pi two of things how you map spheres
into different topological spaces how do
you map three spheres into different
topological spaces one of the things
that this is very useful for is
something called topological defects in
cosmology if you ever heard of cosmic
strings or magnetic monopoles these are
classified by these homotopic groups so
pi 0 the number of connected components
is related in field theory to things
called domain walls we'll explain later
why this is true hopefully PI 1 helps
you calculate whether or not there are
cosmic strings
pi2 tells you whether or not there are
monopoles which is kind of fun there's
even something called textures which are
classified by pi/3 textures are not
quite as respectable as the other one so
naturally because they can sort of
dissolve away in physical fact they're
not stable like the other ones are and
so of course I wrote several papers
about textures in fact I wrote a whole
paper doing nothing but calculating the
homotopic group pi/3 of different spaces
so you can figure out whether or not
different field theories gave rise to
textures okay so this is a long video
sorry about that but I wanted to squeeze
in two topics at once because as fun as
these are both geometry and topology
they are mathematical facts not facts
about the physical world so there are
mathematical ideas the ideas are
absolutely big they're absolutely
crucial and it's important to do them
and I wanted to do things in a slightly
different way like you may have heard
before that the parallel postulate is
not true in non Euclidean geometry you
may have heard before that coffee cups
can be deformed into donuts but I wanted
to give you a little bit of the feeling
of how actual physicists and
mathematicians make use of these facts
how they quantify them how they turn
them into equations they turn them into
things that you can then calculate and
then put to use and we're not actually
gonna be calculating that much in the
rest of the videos but we will be
putting these concepts to use everything
I taught told you about here today will
appear very soon in other videos so
still more big ideas to come